Gundrota: As much as we love
web apps,
they don't work
in many situations
when you lose connectivity
or have intermittent
connectivity.
And there are a lot
of scenarios
that we wish our web apps
could work.
One of the challenges
is that there's no local storage
and no way to store
the application state or code.
That is until recently.
What the HTML 5 standards
of Database and App Cache
allow you do is really approach
the problem of offline,
or even
in the online scenario,
store and cache
the resources you need
for a faster application.
Let's show you
how this works.
Let's go
into the first demo.
First demo, I'm in Safari,
I've got a little app,
it creates a sticky note,
and I can, uh, you know,
create some sort of data.
And if we go
into the developer tool here,
inspect the element,
go into the Database,
you'll see that sure enough,
the notes I'm writing
are pushed down
into that SQLite
database.
But let's lose
the connection.
Okay. No connection.
No Ethernet connection.
Can you go to google.com?
Okay, good. My favorite web site
is inaccessible.
We really are offline.
Let's try creating another note.
Okay, so the note
continues to work.
The JavaScript's all there.
Uh, the data is being pushed
into the SQL database.
Now you must be wondering, okay,
you got the data
in the database,
but where is the app?
Well, let's look
at the manifest
because the standard points us
to a way to actually, uh,
have pointers into
the storage system which high--
which, uh, point to where
the code is, the JavaScript code
and the other resources
that you need.
And so there you can see where
the JavaScript CSS images,
uh, and other things are stored
so that when you're
in an offline state,
well, you can rehydrate
all those resources,
and the app just works.
Let's show you
a more advanced example.
This is an Android phone,
and what you're looking at
here on Android is Gmail.
It's really, really rich Gmail.
You can see the colored labels,
for those of you
who are Gmail users,
you've come to know and love.
Um, as Matt moves around,
you see that floating toolbar
that moves with him--
that's all implemented, uh,
in this particular app,
and it's very, very fast.
You click a message,
it opens up.
Here's the kicker.
Look at the top of the screen.
This is an Android device
that's in offline mode.
It has no connectivity.
In fact, what you're
looking at is a web app,
utilizing the great
new capabilities
of the Android browser
to have support
for these HTML 5 standards.
This particular app, Gmail
on Android or on the iPhone,
is already shipping.
In fact, it's Google's
first big HTML 5 app,
and really demonstrates
the power of what's possible.
And as these phones get faster,
these web apps
just get better
and better and better.
Whether it be better
JavaScript performance,
or the CPU of the phone
gets better,
or the network connectivity
gets faster,
these really become
more and more capable,
and another example of Google
moving towards HTML 5.
Okay, let's go back to slides.
Of course, we're not the only
company who's, uh--who's--
really has invested in the web.
Another company that has
pivoted their strategy
around an
open web platform is Palm.
And to talk about that,
I'd like to invite up Michael.
Michael Abbott,
Senior Vice President of Palm.
Welcome Michael.
Michael and Greg.
Gonna talk about this, yes.
Abbott: Thanks a lot, Vic.
Uh, good morning
to everyone here.
Um, I think that, uh,
one of the interesting things
that I was thinking about
yesterday is that
if it was a year ago,
and you were at this conference,
I'm not too sure many of you
would've predicted
that Palm would be at stage
here at Google I/O.
And, uh, one of the key things
I think why we're here
is that we share
a very common vision.
Or a similar vision.
And that is indeed that the web
is really the platform.
And as we step back in time
from when we were designing
and architecting webOS,
we were thinking through,
how could we actually
enable developers
to have a program model
that we're used to,
but at the same time
offer access to both
services in the cloud
as well as on the device?
And so what we did was
we have built up a platform
with the browser as really
the core construct.
And more concretely,
actually using WebKit
as the core rendering engine
in WebOS.
So all of the core applications
that are built
as a part of WebOS--
mail, contacts, and calendar--
are all built in HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript
as applications on--
in this environment.
So if you look
at a little more details
of what one of these
applications really look like,
you can see that
we have an HTML page
that defines a layout
of the application,
we have JavaScript that--
which can define transitions,
animations,
access storage on the device,
and we might use CSS
to style the applications.
Now, for developers we have
a framework called
the Mojo framework
that allows you to style
applications in beautiful ways
and at the same time
be very performate.
Now, with this program model
that we're offering,
certainly standards
is really important to us,
and HTML 5 is a really
key aspect of WebOS 1.0.
And so we're gonna show you
just a couple quick demos
of how we've actually
deployed and leveraged HTML 5
in the initial version
of the platform.
So we'll switch over.
So, the first thing
I'm gonna show you
is just an example of the canvas
tag in our calendar application.
You can see the way
we're using it
is to actually get really
high-performance scrolling
as Greg actually scrolls
up and down in the day view.
So that's just
one example there.
And this example we're gonna
show you is CSS transformations.
So this is in our
music application,
and you can see that we're
using CSS transformations
to rotate the album art.
Again, this application
is all built in HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript.
And the last example
I'm gonna show you
is with HTML 5 database.
And we're using
that HTML 5 database
as a mechanism to store user's
history as well as browsers.
Now, within this
development environment,
there's a set of services
that are on the device--
uh, we'll get to the next slide.
That we want to offer
and expose up,
from the hardware
in this particular case,
into that development
environment.
And the Accelerometer
is one of these extensions
that we'd like to see in HTML 5.
What we've done is offered up
various events
into that JavaScript run time
so, for example, events around
shaking, acceleration,
and orientation,
and expose those events up
through a DOM Level 2 interface
into JavaScript.
Now, there are certainly
other types of events like this
that--as a result
of that deep integration
between the software
and hardware--
makes a lotta sense,
certainly for the mobile
computing platform,
and that's actually
one of the key things that--
that we're interested
in working with you on over time
which is how do we actually
really bring in both the mobile
and the desktop development
environments together.
If you look at an example
of how we're actually doing
this type of integration
of the applications
using these accelerometer API,
you can see that
we define a set of events,
and then you as a developer
can go and define
the handling of those events.
So depending on how you want
to leverage the accelerometer
in your application, it's very
simple to access these events
and leverage these within
that JavaScript
programming environment.
So again, what we see
for HTML 5 and WebOS
is really a key convergent point
between the mobile platform
and the desktop platform,
and we're very interested
in working with you over time
to extend all the various
events and access services
from these hardware platforms
into this run time.
Thank you.
[applause]
Gundrota: Thank you. Thank you.
Okay, App Cache, Database--
broadly adopted today
in these browsers.
Finally, let me talk
about Web Workers.
You know, as the web
becomes more powerful,
and you build better
and better apps
that become richer and bigger,
uh, you do run
into some problems.
Problems that native
applications have solved.
For example, any of you
who've written applications
with large amounts of JavaScript
understand the challenge
of having the UI freeze
as you do JavaScript parsing.
It's not pretty.
but unfortunately
it's unavoidable
as your JavaScript
gets larger and larger.
How do we solve this problem?
Well, in a native application,
you could spawn
a background thread.
You could, uh, have
background processing.
And that's exactly
what the HTML 5 standard
of web workers allows you to do.
Let me show you some demos.
Let's move over to screen one.
There we go.
This particular example
just calculates, um,
some prime numbers.
And so we've got a couple
of tabs open there.
You can see we've got
the New York Times and so forth.
Uh, Matt, why don't you go ahead
and start the demo?
And now try clicking
on another tab.
Uh, exactly.
So the JavaScript parsing
is completely hosing
not only the tab--
the UI of the tab--
but as well as
the rest of the browser.
Let's redo that demo.
This time let's look
at the source.
Same demo, but look
We made a change.
And you see there
Matt highlighting the use
of the background processing
via the Web Worker.
Let's run that same app again.
Number one, the UI
is responsive,
the other tabs are responsive,
and it all just works.
Right? New capability.
Background processing
in the browser from JavaScript.
That's just really,
really great.
Let me--
[applause]
Hold your applause.
If you like that,
wait 'til you see this.
Uh, this demo is my favorite.
Okay, it's using the canvas tag
to place the boxes,
it's using the video tag
to play the video,
it's using JavaScript
and Web Workers
to run some
background processing.
Let me tell you
what's gonna happen.
We're gonna start the video,
and you're gonna see a lady
walk by the vi--on the video.
JavaScript is gonna run
and do motion detection,
and then draw via canvas
a bounding box around the object